welcome to this meeting of Baba District
Council cabinet I'm councelor John Ward
acting leader of Baba District Council
and I'll be chairing this meeting we
have um somewhat um depleted cabinet
today due to a number of illnesses and
other things so um however we will
continue may I first of all remind you
of some domestic arrangements please
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use that you do
not interrupt other speakers that if you
are attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave please ensure your
mobile phones are on silent or Switched
Off and additionally we will be using EV
voting for this meeting on the modern.
goov app I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded I'll now move to the
agenda item one apologies for
absence thank you chair we have
apologies from councel Sally Davies
councelor alist mcro councelor Dave
Busby and councelor Daniel Porter thank
you item two to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registerable or non-reg
interest by
members are there any to
declare
NOP and in accordance with the delegated
authority the monitoring officer has
granted dispensations to all members in
respect of the 2024 to 25 budget
papers
item three paper BCA 2338 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of January
2024 I just go through these starting at
page five on your agenda
pack excuse me page
six page
seven page
eight page
nine page
10 page
11 page
12 page
13 and finally page
so if there
are no points regarding the accuracy of
the minutes may I have a proposal please
Council saw and a seconder councelor
Derek
Davis so noct vote thank you chair that
votee is now in progress thank
you
counselor s may I take your V
verbally councelor Davies may take your
vot
verbally
thank you chair that's four votes for
and one abstention that's
carried thank you right um moving on
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
chair item five questions by councilors
none received chair item six matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint udit and standards committees
there are no matter referred
chair okay moving on cabinet members
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list does anyone have any comments over
the contents of
that nope right
okay next is item seven paper BCA 2339
the general fund budget for 2024 to 25
and fouryear
Outlook I will now as the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments
introduce this
report
I'm pleased to introduce report BCA 2339
for the 2024 to 25 general fund budget
and fouryear Outlook in addition to the
main report there is also a table paper
which contains some important updates
and I'll hopefully ensure that I'm clear
when I talk about each of
them we have to set a a balanced budget
but the budget presented in this report
currently shows a gap and this is I'm
referring to the main paper between
forecast expenditure and income of
$846,000
although the table paper has updated
this and reduced that number the table
paper also has final estimates for
several budget items that are not in the
main report financing costs costs
arising from likely regulatory changes
in accounting for loan impairments and
the final Finance settlement from
central government and lastly the table
paper includes some options that we need
to consider and agree today for
recommendation to
Council in the past we've used a worst
case scenario when putting budget
proposals together which has often
resulted in unders spends which have had
unintended consequences for the budget
setting
process for the current year stretching
but realistic assumptions were used
setting the budget and uh and that was
done last February however Global events
Rising inflation and Rising interest
rates coupled with reduced demand for
planning Services have seen a marked
deterioration in the council's finances
throughout the current Financial year
which will end in a forecast deficit at
least at a quarter two of forecast
deficit of 9
£22,000 against an original budgeted
surplus of
22,000 a summary of the 2023 to 24
budget forecast are provided in
paragraphs 4.5 to 4.8 of the report
however this is a moving picture and
quarter three is going to show a slight
Improvement on
that the National Economic position is
summarized in paragraph 4.4 the impacts
on us are three-fold firstly
inflationary pressures for items such as
energy Fuel and utilities alongside
inflation link contra rual cost
increases and also the need to agree a
fair affordable payoff of for staff
secondly the high interest rates have
meant that our financing costs
particularly in obtaining short-term
loans have increased
significantly and thirdly no major
changes to departmental spending plans
have meant that the finance settlement
despite the recently announced increase
is a below inflation increase again it
is only a one-year
settlement the government has been very
vocal in saying that councils and I
quote will see an average uh on average
an above inflation increase of 7% in
their C spending power next
year and that includes a funding
guarantee of 4% before taking into
account increases in council tax or any
other locally generated income yes
inflation is now 4.6% but it has been
much higher than 7% only falling below
that in July and we will be feeling the
consequences well into the future and
this funding Guaranty masks a
significant decrease in the services
Grant the government continues to say
that council tax referendum thresholds
are neither minimum amounts nor caps and
that and again I quote it is for
individual local authorities to
determine whether to use the
flexibilities taking into consideration
the pressures many households are
facing this is rather disingenuous
because the promised 7% increase in core
spending power assumes that we will
increase council tax up to the
referendum
limit the government has also asked
local authorities to use their reserves
to maintain Services well we will be
doing that and we will talk about that
later but it's not a long-term strategy
reserves can only be used
once moving on to the details of the
budget first I want to run through the
key points in the main report the 2024
budget has taken the 2023 to 24 forecast
position as a starting point but with a
number of budget items the employees
budget Grant income from central
government financing costs interest
income and business B and Council ta
income being forecast from a zero base a
lot of work has gone into identifying
efficiencies savings and income
opportunities to balance the budget but
at the moment more needs to be done to
achieve this and strengthen the
short-term Financial resilience of the
council the budget summary is provided
in table one in paragraph 5.4 and the
charts in paragraph
5.5 gross expenditure is 25.4 million
and income is £1.5 million giving a net
cost of service of1 14.9 million funding
totals 14.07 million leaving a current
forecast budget Gap as stated in that
report of 846
th000 and you'll see from the table that
the net cost of services increased by
19% this uh net cost includes the
changes to fees and charges agreed by
cabinet last
month and these also include those set
by government which we can't control and
those over which we do have control and
for which we have adopted a policy of
full cost
recovery we are forecasting a small
decrease in sales season charges income
compared with the current Year's budget
due to the on ongoing downturn in
planning Fe fee income only partly
mitigated by the planning fee increases
that the government has recently
announced table two in paragraph 5.6
shows the 2024 to 25 budget pressures
and savings compared with the current
year with the key assumptions described
in paragraphs 5.7 to
5.13 there are new cost pressures of
just over4 million identified Savings of
1.7 million and an increase in funding
of 1.5 million pound pounds plus last
year's budget surplus leading to the
overall
stated deficit in that table of $846,000
in terms of the funding settlement and
new homes bonus details of the the
funding settlement are provided in
paragraphs 5.14 to
5.18 the
count the um the council's
um
sorry council's 2024 to 25 grant
allocation including new homes bonus has
increased by
149,000 pounds which is 11. uh 11%
compared with 2023 to 24 and it's 103
more than the original
46 uh 2,000 stated in paragraph 515 of
the main report as a result of the
recently announced Finance
settlement £85.3 th000 of this funding
is due to an increase in new homes bonus
resulting from our increased housing
delivery without this the final funding
numbers are less generous than they seem
turning around a provisional decrease
into a 63.9 th000 increase we will again
be using all of the new homes bonus
allocation to balance the budget
information about new homes bonus
payments over the years are provided in
paragraphs 519 to
5.22 in terms of council tax cour our
funding is the need to have a strong
council tax base and so the numbers
produce a compelling case of the need
for council tax increases at re refer
threshold of 2.99% each year this means
a rise of £54 6 to 8810 perom or
£362 £362 p a week for a bande property
we also agreed last month to impose an
empty homes premium after one year
instead of two years these measures will
provide an additional £ 352,000 of
council tax funding after taking into
account revised income bands and
contribution rates for the local counc
council tax reduction scheme in which
the shown in table five in paragraph
5.27 We Are forecasting a total 5.9
million pounds funding from business
rates although the Baseline rates amount
after tariff and Levy um is almost the
same as the current year and the pooling
share has decreased we have had some
quite large increases including the fact
that we won't be top slicing uh the the
business rates growth to the suff public
sector Le leaders group leaders group so
that gives us an extra £300,000
there's also been a significant increase
in section 31 Grant due largely to the
continuing freeze of the small business
rate multiplier
and we've also got uh now a large prior
year business rate Surplus because we're
able to reduce the provision for the
impact of successful appeals and a
detailed explanation of this can be
found in paragraph
5.28 I'd now like to draw your attention
to the table paper you'll see from the
amended budget position in table three
in paragraph 5.1 that we now have more
or less closed the Gap since the over
and scrutiny committee report last month
and also the recently published cabinet
report and that we have had to do this
there has been a huge amount of work put
into this and we have been fortunate in
that there are some large one-off
payments movements in in um uh a number
of budget items
there in addition to the section 31
business rates and and and prior year
business rate Surplus I've mentioned
we've also got additional CCO income as
a result of canceling further deferred
debt repayments from
cifco and there's also been a large
credit um in terms of of the H's share
of short-term borrowing interest costs
and that's been credited to the general
fund because because those costs are
credited to the and now charged to the
HRA paragraph 3.3 explains this in more
detail and replaces paragraph 5 5.13 in
the main
report however there are some
significant additional pressures that
are not included table one in paragraph
4.1 shows that we still need to fund a
budget pressure of just under1 1.9
million the table shows how this number
is derived and resources that can be
made available I want now to explain
what this table is
saying now firstly the expected deficit
for the current year at quarter 3 is an
improvement on quarter 2 which I
mentioned
earlier the latest deficit for 2024 to
25 um is um in in the main report and
the general fund credit for HRA
borrowing is also included there and
there are also two items relating to um
an ecl Reserve that needs further
explanation the government is getting
tougher on third party loans and the
expectation that that it will reduce MRP
Min minimum Revenue provision on such
loans within the next 12 months our
treasury management advisers have
calculated an expected credit loss to
measure the credit risk of these loans
and we need to account for this in the
budget this affects our two third party
loans to cfco and V growth and the
amounts are shown in that table more
information provided in paragraphs 3.5
to
3.12 we'll be setting up an ecl Reserve
to be able to cover these as we expect
to have to include by the time the 2024
to 25 outturn is produced The Net result
of all this is that we need to find 1.9
million pound the rest of the table
shows what is proposed to address this
shortfall and protect us from unexpected
future budget shortfalls firstly a
number of aark reserves will be
repurposed to the ecl reserve and also
new Financial resilience Reserve Reserve
to provide short-term funding of budget
gaps this will have an impact as stated
in the table secondly some capital
projects will be reprofiled to save
interest payments of £173,000 and this
is also included in table one the
details for both of these proposals are
shown in table
two just a quick um comment about the
reserves the latest position for the
aark reserves is shown in table five of
the table paper it includes the purpose
the proposed repurposed reserves I want
to draw your attention to paragraph 4.5
regarding the general fund unmarked
Reserve which is1
million reverse Financial resilience
Reserve is a prudent measure at this
point to ensure that we are able to meet
any in-year deficits or overspending in
2024 to 25 and
Beyond moving on to the The medium-term
View forecasts for the funding pressures
and savings and income for the next four
years are provided in section seven of
the main report but this is out of date
and it will be updated for the council
meeting because unfortunately there
hasn't been time to do this for today
any medium-term forecast would have to
be treated with caution however due to
increasing uncertainties on costs and
funding we do know that we are likely to
be looking at a cumulative budget gap
between two and3 million pound over the
next three to four years the measures we
are taking are described in section
eight of the main report the review
remodel reinvent approach is well
established but I think there will be
changes and I think it's fair to say um
I'm looking at the chief executive now
that um he's already indicated that the
remodel will be given greater
emphasis the measures will ensure that
we will be able to meet any challenges
in 2024 to 25 and they will give us time
to look at options to ensure future year
spending is able to be balanced by
available
resources the revised Capital program is
shown in table six of the table paper
and it includes 6.8 million pound of
reprofiled capital projects listed in
table two
the plan spend for 2024 to2 is now 9
million down from 15.8
million so in summary a lot of work has
gone into balancing the budget in the
short term but this has required
repurposing reserves so reducing what
can be used elsewhere this use of
reserves as I said can only be done once
the remaining aark reserves really must
remain committed to for funding the
purpose for which they were originally
established this Still Remains the
problem of a medium-term forecast and
work will start in the spring to
continue to make efficiencies and
productivity savings and find new ways
of working I'm confident that we will
recognize that that we do recognize the
situation and we'll be able to make the
necessary
decisions and finally to remind you as
part of the debate I want you to confirm
that you agree with the reserve and
capital program changes proposed in
table two of the table
paper I'd like therefore to propose the
recommendations in paragraphs 3.1 to 3.4
of the main report and paragraph 2.1 of
the table report
and ask for a
second may I have a
second councel Helen Davis thank
you right members of the cabinet any
questions is a lot to take in um and in
fact we do have the two papers um one
that does substantially replace sections
of the other um is is difficult at this
stage but it was the only way of getting
the information to us in time by the
time we get to the council meeting it'll
all be Consolidated in in a one final
paper councilor Derek
Davis yeah so on that point um there's
still a lot of imponderables in there so
how confident are you that the officers
are going to be able to to get all the
information that's needed because as you
say it's a very difficult budget what
they always are but this is even more
challenging and there's still a lot of
um income outcome outgoing that we're
not 100% aware of for example the baber
growth the issues around
that well the the specifics around um
those uh um ecl uh numbers for bab
growth and CCO um obviously the detail
is not known the timing is not known
which is why we're we're setting aside
um Provisions that our treasury advisers
have have suggested we should make in
that Reserve so that um when the time
comes at some point during the year we
will be able to to uh to draw on that
Reserve but
um at the moment I don't think there's
anything more that uh that I can say
about that at this stage but we are
making um by by setting up that Reserve
we're making sure that we can handle
that um if when it hits
us I notic in the mark reserves that the
80,000 that what was going to be um paid
towards um free port in mids suffk is
that now dead we're not going to give
them any more
money even going forward yeah that that
item and if I just get um maybe Karen
could perhaps um confirm that that item
should be taken out of the reserve
shouldn't
it
uh that that is correct
chair yeah my understanding is that that
was actually put into the reserves and
error that um babber did not have that
um did not need to make that
payment are there any other
questions Council
s um yes chair um first of all um I uh
totally um support the idea of a
financial resilience uh Reserve that's
very
prudent um obviously I'm sure that the
the issue that worries um all cabinet
members
is how we are going to if at all
replenish um our
reserves uh going forward and uh
obviously it doesn't help to um produce
a medium-term
um strategy when uh it looks like uh
government uh settlements will always be
one year and in terms of Reserve
replenishment that that is something
that has got to be addressed as as part
of the work that um we embark on after
the budget has been approved by by
Council
um we are drawing heavily at the moment
but yes we we do need to make sure not
just that we are that um we've closed
the the forecast Gap over the the medium
term but also have sufficient funds to
replenish reserves in terms of
government
settlements they have um been oneye
settlements for for quite some time now
um I don't think anyone can can say
anything more about that because we have
no idea who will be the government in a
year's time and what their policy will
be towards Local Government
funding
coun s um I recall that when um the
County
Council um announced its uh budget um
that there were certain of their
obligations particularly is regarding
homelessness that they wish to
um transfer to the
districts uh do we have any more
indication of the of the of that uh
Quantum and um what it might the impact
might be on
us it was more the case of they they
wanted uh to no longer um meet their
commitment or earlier commitments to um
uh to that um the it wasn't so much
transferring to the district but it was
a recognition by the districts and Bs
that we would have to pick there would
be some impact on us and um we would
have to pick up some of the Pieces
perhaps in from that decision
um there's been a lot of work and
discussions to and fro between um the
directors of housing amongst the
districts and burs in the county to to
try to to work out the and quantify the
impact um that that's not I don't think
there's there's a final understanding
yet apart from the fact that um there
clearly will be and there will be a cost
um but I can't say anything more than
that at the moment um again Karen um do
you have any further comment on that or
Deborah
perhaps you you might um thank you chair
um only to say that this there are
ongoing discussions and in fact there's
a meeting next week to discuss the
impact um with with housing um provide
with councils and with
County so so so we'll update you when we
have any definitive news on that thank
you
any other
questions in which
case oh Castle s yeah go
ahead apologies um uh obviously looking
at the uh medium term
um we we recognize that um for some time
we've been talking about uh a new Depot
for our uh waste operations and of
course um
within the medium term um the government
um will be
mandating their new um waste
strategy um now obviously we would hope
that the um government would
um be pragmatic with their new new
burden uh funding but um I have we made
provision for for both of those
um but both for the de for the depo and
and the changes that are coming in uh as
regards um waste and recycling because
uh It Whatever government is in power it
doesn't look to me like we are going to
get a generous settlement new new burden
funding in terms of the Depo we've still
got that in the capital program um
there's there's that commitment for that
um and we do need to progress with that
that because that is something we we we
simply have to do we can't we can't um
postpone that um in terms of new burdens
funding for uh implementing the the
measures that uh contained within rolls
resources and waste
strategy it does seem from the latest
I've heard that we're definitely going
to get full Capital um new burdens
funding for for capital expenditure but
um it does seem to be some uncertainty
over Revenue expenditure um at the
moment we're not um forecasting anything
in the medium term in terms of any
potential impact um from from RW but
that that's clearly something we have to
look at in in detail again um during the
the course of the
Year any questions more questions if oh
counc Helen
Davis
come on excellent um just with respect
to the income we
receive
tax if we're putting the council tax up
presumably that means a certain number
of residents will then find themselves
unable to
pay
um have we
calculated what we expect to happen as a
result of that increase in the council
tax per se because you might just put it
up by
2.99% and think you're going to get X in
but you actually only get Y in because
people suddenly put up their hand and
say
sorry I'll ask Karen to uh to answer
that but before I do I think the the
working age um house tax reduction
scheme
probably mitigates a lot of that as as
much as it can but um whether um as a
result of changes to the the thresholds
for that uh take people out of that
scheme and and make them more
um and then they have to be themselves
have to pay more Council taxes as a
result of no longer qualifying I don't I
don't know Karen do you do you have any
further comment on
that I'm sorry chair I'm not in
possession of that detail knowledge we'd
have to investigate and get a written
response back U probably from the
revenues
partnership um certainly thanks Karen
yeah it would be Wonder to to get detail
from the SRP but um we have we do have
very high council tax collection rates
so I I think um past Year's experience
has shown that there probably not a
significant
issue Council Carter sorry it wasn't a
question but just to come back on
um I think that Council Chex is probably
up there on the list of things for
people to pay um what will happen closer
the
sorry uh due to due to what will happen
if you won't pay it um and there are
schemes in place to be able to to help
people um but we're not actively sort of
searching those people out people have
to come forward so I suppose it's just
the knowledge to say if you are
struggling get in touch we might be able
to help you um but generally rent rent
and council tax are what people will go
um they they'll go without other things
to be able to to pay those
unfortunately it's a hard time for
everyone if there no further questions
from the council
s
um so um it would seem that one of the
um unintended
consequences of this is
that um as a council we we are trying to
preserve are the services that we um the
discretionary services and the statutary
services that we offer our our
residents um I know that we have had
conversations about um a diff different
ways of um addressing the need of our of
our
residents and maybe transforming
um the way we offer
services
um and I would presume uh that this work
will go on once once this uh budget is
um finalized that we will have to do
more of this work to ensure that we can
balance the budget in future
years
um whilst still maintaining
um the uh the level of service that we
we offer our our
residents uh am I right in assuming that
is what we're trying to do I I I think
so I think that's um I'll let the chief
e um come in in a sec but I think in
terms of the aspiration of the
administration that is what we want to
do a thank you chair yes absolutely so
that work has begun already rather than
waiting until the council finally
approves the budget um but the intention
is very much that whilst this budget is
being balanced through extensive use of
reserves that is not something that can
be sustained on a long-term basis nor is
it sensible financial management on a
long-term basis so the intention would
be both in the following year or this
forthcoming year that wherever possible
whilst we have set a budget that relies
upon the use of those reserves that in
reality we do not uh end up spending
those reserves and instead build Savings
in that means that your end of year
position has relied Less on reserves I
don't think I can hand on heart say that
you're going to have no spend from
reserves in the course of the financial
year but certainly would want to rewind
that as best possible so you're setting
a if you like setting a technical
balanced budget um and hope to improve
that position during the course of the
year but fundamentally Council saw you
were right which is uh we cannot as
babber continue to things in the way
that we have in the past and that will
mean extremely difficult decisions which
is either we do less which nobody
politically I suspect will want to sign
up to but nonetheless is the harsh
reality of the way this council is
funded or rather not funded um but also
that we fundamentally relook at how
things are delivered which might be more
in terms of enabling Services rather
than Direct Delivery um working more
closely with our communities working
more closely with partners and therefore
delivering things in a fundamentally
different way so the outcomes are still
achieved but they aren't achieved by the
council directly doing it for people uh
but clearly that transition is not a
simple thing to do and nor are we alone
fortunately because uh lots of councils
are in a very similar situation so we
will be able to lean on The Wider local
government Network for support in terms
of looking at how others are doing
things but I don't think it's realistic
nor can I promise you that there won't
be some very difficult decisions for the
politicians to have to make
in terms of prioritizing elements of
services rather than actual full
services but elements of services over
other things and it will have
consequences for residents as a
result thank
you any further cabinet questions before
I move on to other
members in which case other members
Council McLaren you have a question
thank you chair
I um if we look at the chart on page 20
of the of the
papers um what sort of struck me was
that uh the expenditure for 23 24 the
senior leadership team actually spent
more money than the directorate of
communities and
well-being um and I
wondered perhaps why that was then we go
on to page 23 where we've got the
expectation of
2425 and just looking again at those two
areas those specific areas then there's
a very dramatic difference and I
wondered if somebody could explain that
to me or if that's not possible today
somebody could let me know I would be
very interested to know how those
Figures were arrived at thank
you
um I will ask if
the chief executive do you have uh
comment on on those differences at the
moment or is that something we have to
get back I can give you an initial
observation I think you look at chart
one where you
can yes so uh as you'll appreciate we
have a very small communities and
wellbeing team I think is the is the
answer to that question so whilst we do
what we do in relation to communities
and wellbeing uh it's not statutary
service it's something that has grown
over time uh and refer back to my
previous comments as to whether we can
sustain that at that level uh but
certainly we do not have a a significant
number of Staff working in that area in
terms of the senior leadership team I'm
currently making or proposing changes to
the senior leadership team which will
bring those costs
down I think the differences between the
two charts is that the communities and
well-being had increased absolutely
significantly um where the SLT had had
increased but only slightly but um
Community U I don't know Tom do you have
comment on that
in terms of the the communities um the
increase from LA or the current year to
the Future year is gone up
from 735 million to 1.3 million so
that's almost well it's it's about a 90%
increase um through you chair I need to
take that away and provide a detailed
answer outside the meeting thank you do
that
Council clar can I just follow that up
with the chief executive again okay um
can you just so um in terms of
directorates then the director
themselves that cost does not come in
with the directorate expense is that
true yes so the way in which you've got
this presented here shows the cost of
the director sitting with the senior
leadership team rather than sitting
within the directorate yes I don't think
I think for anybody outside side looking
at that that could be a bit um
confusing thank
you I'm more than happy J if we want to
not show any cost of C the leadership
team and absorb it into each director
but I suspect there would be a question
as to where's the transparency around
that as well but yes you're absolutely
right to flag that's how that's
presented in the
papers any further
questions okay members of the cabinet
we're we're through to now does anyone
wish to to make any any
comments councelor Derek
Davis yeah as we've said before it is a
very difficult budget and we are going
to still have to make some tough choices
going forward as has been pointed out we
can't carry on the way we have been
carried on and and we've already made a
start in terms of full cost recovery
or or towards full cost recovery for a
lot of our services which are statutory
and and those other ones um that are not
and I hate to say but car parking
charges has to be included in that not
just for this year but for the years
going forward as well what I am pleased
though and and to pick up councelor
Davis's point is that we have looked at
things like council tax charges and the
income band support um which totally
backs up councelor Carter's um point in
that we are looking after our residents
for those that are finding the cost of
living crisis difficult um and this
budget has balanced that um by do by
making sure that we look after the um
the most vulnerable residents in the
district I think we've still got a lot
of work to do um as councilor Source
pointed out we need to replenish the
reserves at some point because you know
it's going to rain again and we need to
make sure that that we're robust enough
to deal with that but I think this
is it's a it's a it's a good start and I
think the officers and and yourself
councel award that have been involved in
putting this together have done a very
very good job in very difficult Ser
circumstances and I think as a Cabinet
we should um we should support it thank
you Council s um referring back to the
um uh communities and uh
wellbeing I think uh one of the uh
striking factors in the uh increase in
um expenditure is obviously the work
that the council does in in helping um
residents deal with the cost of living
crisis um I was talking to U the chair
of um
subury uh citizens advice um um quite
recently and um they have a piece of
research that shows um that there are uh
over 7,000 uh individuals in the
district who um who are not necessarily
in receipt of benefit but are Income
deprived I.E their salaries their wages
do not cover um their
outgoings and the communities uh Team
have been um very successful in getting
funding um from other organizations and
is in fact kind of a a good Exemplar of
the of the partnership model because I
think the Integrated Health Board would
find it quite difficult to to actually
offer services uh without um the help of
the of the district council um and uh so
I think uh
whereas we obviously should look at at
at that expenditure we should also be
conscious uh that this team is its its
scope of work has increased um
exponentially over the last couple of
years and given the cuts that there are
in in both at the county level um it it
is a a a very difficult uh set of
circumstances to try and to to work
round because we want to help people but
we also have to be conscious of the cost
of that um but I would say that the
communities team are um very um Adept in
um uh securing grants from other
organizations and uh I think that's
something that we will uh definitely as
a council be uh spending uh more time
ensuring that we can get grants from
from other places if grants there
be thank
you does anyone else wish to say
anything oh Tom sorry
was just if if I can add into the the
debate um just to flag that chart one
and chart three are not actually
directly comparable and this picks up
the point that councilor saw was making
that chart three is the gross
expenditure and so it is a more
significant amount because the community
team are spending money that isn't the
councils they're spending money that has
been gained from external grants or from
other partners such as health I will
still provide you with a detailed
breakdown to address your question but
ultimately a significant part of that
difference is that one is gross and the
other
isn't thank you
Tom Council
Carter at risk of repeating what's
already been said
um it
is difficult um it's it's really it's an
awful position to be in um at the moment
we're not as bad as some other councils
um but
to use the reserves I suppose to cover
our bank now or try not to but but to to
use the reserves to cover our back nail
and then looking forward to not only
replace those but to carry on services
or increase help to others it
is concerning and it is difficult um but
I think that um transparency and
communication with our residents is key
throughout this whole proc process to
let them know what's going on um and to
say we're we're not no no one wants to
cut anything no one wants to raise
council tax but these things have to be
done um so that we don't fall into a
position where we can't do
anything
um yeah it's say again it's an awful
position to be in but I think we've done
well with what is here um but looking
forward
forward we need to think of something um
and just just talk to people and make
them aware and say this is what we're
doing and this is why we're doing
it thank you and and it's it's not just
a question of trying to avoid Cuts but
there's certain aspirations that that
we've agreed we want to try to um to do
over the next three to four years and
it's been able to have the funding to to
achieve those aspirations and that's
that's the really important thing in
terms of communication you're absolutely
right we do need to constantly get out
there and explain and and as much as
possible to as wide an audience as
possible because there are those out
there who are spreading disinformation
and we do need to counter
that okay anything else anyone or shall
we move to oh first of all just in terms
of
the um the uh suggestions
recommendations in the table paper with
regard to the reserve movements and the
the capital
program um re uh repurposing and and
reprofiling to later years are we happy
with that because that's going to form
uh key to the U the report when it goes
to Council in terms of the uh decisions
we we have to make so are we happy with
with what suggested there particularly
on the capital
program
there there are significant items that
are being repurposed as as explained
um in in the the table paper um but uh
the the the um the amount in terms of
interest interest uh payment savings
173,000 doesn't sound a lot but it is it
is uh still a significant and and useful
contribution um the there are number I
obviously nobody wants to uh to postpone
any of those uh in an ideal world but
these are the ones that perhaps can be
postponed with the the least impact in
terms of some of some of the
others councelor Derek Davis yeah
broadly I'm very supportive but I I
would disc caution about throwing good
money after bad in in some cases um but
but also looking on the positive side
we've got a lot of good things coming up
and I know you know using my economics
team for growth and regeneration as an
example um they're working on a number
of of ways of increasing Revenue to the
district you know skills wise investment
wise bringing more uh energy and more
economy to to the district so I think
that's really good and I think in terms
of the capital program as long as we
invest wisely um then it is it's money
well spent but we need to be cautious
that we Bank the right horses if you if
you like on that one
um yeah I'll leave it there okay and
broadly supportive
right and I assume if nobody says no
then you're all you're all in favor
in which case if there's nothing else
that anyone wishes to say we can move to
the
vote
okay thank you chair that vote is now in
progress thank
you
thank you chair that's five votes for
that's unanimous thank
you right moving on
then it's item 9 paper BCA 2340 the
housing revenue account 2024 to 25 bud
um and so again as the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments it
falls upon me to introduce this
report I'm pleased to introduce report
BCA 2340 for the 2024 to 25 housing
revenue account revenue and capital
budgets as with the general fund the
situation with the HRA is increasingly
challenging the same inflationary
pressures are having a huge impact and
we are suffering the after effects of
the rent policy of 2015 to2 20 and also
last year's rent cap we are undertaking
a full review of our HRA 30-year
business plan so that it still meets the
council's aspirations our tenants
aspirations and the need to invest in
our aging stock for repairs and Energy
Efficiency improvements while also
ensuring we adhere to the social housing
regulations and the requirements of the
social housing
regulator our budget for 2023 to 24
forecast a deficit of £62,000 which has
increased by 94 £4,000 to just over 1.5
million at Cost two as we know the key
factors affecting this are the
additional costs incurred to address
through repairs backlog as well as
increasing materials costs cabinet
approved the use of reserves to cover
this total
deficit we would have forecast a surplus
of £
343,000 for 2024 to 25 however due to
review of the best use of reserves we
are proposing to make A6 million pound
loan repayment and a 4.5 million pound
increase in Revenue contribution to
Capital these two oneoff measures result
in the position for next year appearing
to have worsened to uh a deficit of
10.36 million pound table one shows the
pressures and savings an additional
income and table two contains the
overall budget
summary the increase in total dwelling
rent income is based on an increase of
7.7% which is CPI plus one on General
needs properties and an increase of
99.4% which is RPI Plus 5 for affordable
housing the average weekly social R rent
will increase by
7.92 sorry
£7.92 from 10288 to £
11081 and the average weekly rent for
affordable housing will increase by
£113 from £ 14451 to
15563 Table Three shows how alternative
scenarios for rent increases would have
impacted the total rent income and table
four shows the cumulative effect of
these scenarios on the h business
plan increases to sheltered housing
service and utility charges will add an
an average of18 and 2 p per week to
bills which is a 37%
rise it is a lot but it will enable us
to recover expected costs and reduce the
risk of the rent payers subsidizing the
sheltered housing schemes garage rents
are also being
increased the reserves are shown in
table five after the deduction for the
10136 million pound budget deficit the
reserves will total 6.4 uh 468 million
and that includes the 1 million pound
working balance General Reserve I just
want to let you know of a minor
correction to the paper paragraph 5.35
should say that the ear Mark reserves
balance is 5.32 million which equates to
1,511 per property so those two numbers
there um need to to be updated U the
table is correct but um it's just that
the the paragraph Was was not updated
the HRA Capital program for 2024 to2 to
2027 to 28 is shown in Table Six the
total proposed Capital spend is 13.7
million for next year which is
substantially greater than the 8 million
pound forecast in last year's budget
both housing maintenance and the new
build and Acquisitions program have
increased spending
proposed the L will deliver an
additional 14 new homes to our stock
this is less than we've been able to do
in recent years we will looking for
further opportunities housing
maintenance is now shown in detail in
the table so that the provision for each
type of work can be
seen the additional Revenue contribution
to Capital that we are drawing from our
strategic Reserve will help the
affordability of the capital program by
reducing the cost of short-term
borrowing in summary there are
challenges with the HRA regulat
compliance the condition of our stock
and the cost of repairs and maintenance
the difficulty in building and acquiring
new homes not to mention the
government's tinkering with r policy
however we are coping and we're about to
complete a comprehensive stock survey
and a new business plan so we know what
we have to do and how and when it will
be done as the report says the Journey
to Excellence will take several years to
complete but we are now seeing progress
being made and I'd like to propose the
recommendations in paragraphs 4.1 to 4.8
which summarize the key budget proposals
and ask for a
seconder council Carter thank
you members of the cabinet any any
questions Council Derek
Davis sorry I just got the one about the
uh um6 million pound repayment going to
the public works loan board obviously I
know someone's done the figures and
they've worked it out but what would
have been the interest rate if we had
chosen that
option this this is this is a um a loan
that we are are repaying rather than
continue with um Jenny
can as as person who's worked on the um
the H budget are you able to provide any
information on that I'm Afra I don't
know how much it would be because
obviously we would be renewing it next
year and it comes up for um it needs to
be repaid next year so we would have to
take out another loan to repay that loan
as it were how much the rates will be
next year I don't know but given you
have good reserves it was a more prudent
decision to pay it off with your
reserves rather than taking the loan out
again um I don't know if Alistair or Sue
um sorry uh Karen would like to add
anything to that Alison do you have
anything uh so was the question around
what would the interest rate be next
year if we were to refinance that loan
yeah pretty much it's because obviously
we're we're going through a very
difficult time time to repay a huge
jump6 million pound you know this year
and know we would have to repay it at
some point or refinance it and I was
just looking at the uh the reason for
not refinancing it and going for a
straight
repayment I mean my my understanding is
that we have the funds U set aside in
reserves to uh to to repay that loan and
it it would therefore it would therefore
be um
prudent to use other funds to repay the
loan um I mean I think that
so I think the in I think the interest
the annual interest on the loan is is
round about 170,000 per anom yeah so
therefore by repaying that loan yeah we
uh we would save ourselves 130 170,000
per anom uh less the interest that we
earn on investing The Six Million that
we've got set aside H but but on balance
it is more prudent to repay the
loan I think Karen you want to say
something Deborah
yes both both of you want to say okay
Karen
first uh the proposed treasury
management strategy that we'll be going
to council alongside the budget report
uh proposes that no long-term borrowing
is undertaken in 2425
given the high interest rates and given
s of current assumptions on interest
rates falling uh from our advisor Sing
close so um it would be prudent not to
enter into a long-term loan that fixes
the Council on sort of what may be
considered artificially High um interest
rates but of course um it's also says in
the
strategy um that this will need to be
reviewed for the next finan Cal year and
also that we need to review it at the
time when the loan is coming close just
to just to assure ourselves that the
value for money for the council is being
obtained by pursuing this course of
action and that would be a it's
regularly reviewed our our lending our
loans our borrowing needs are regularly
reviewed um dur during the year and this
will be part of a review as
well de do you want to say anything as
well
yeah yes um just to add that members may
or may not be aware that um the interest
payable on our loans comes directly out
of our Revenue so should we not should
should we refinance that would put um
significant pressure on our revenue and
of course our ability to carry out um
repairs and maintenance going forward on
our
properties
therefore further prudent reason to uh
pay it off if we have the reserves to do
so thanks
sah Council s
um obviously we've made a a huge
commitment and and a totally proper
commitment to improving our housing
stock and
um like um many districts uh we do have
a homelessness um problem but um looking
forward there may be some of our
housing that
is too expensive to repair let's put it
like this um have
we considered in this plan whether we
are going to
sell um housing stock which which is
um too expensive for us to to keep
within our
stock Deborah can you respond to that
please thank
you uh thank you for the question uh and
it is a a very good question so so this
year we'll be
developing um an asset register and what
that asset register will contain is a
list of all our properties with all our
previous spend our predicted future
spend and from that we'll be able to do
a calculation and understand which
properties um are you know Co costing
the h a substantial amount of money
because of um you know it may be the
bill type um Etc and from that we'll
then be able to develop a strategy in
terms of what properties we keep within
the HRA and what properties we we they
then may choose to sell and of course we
we we could then think about
um within that strategy if if we did
sell properties then to buy properties
which are more um energy efficient and
cost um efficient for our HRA business
plan going
forward thank you
deah any other
questions in which case Council s sorry
um Deborah could you remind me how many
people have or families have we got on
on the homelessness
register um I'm not sure off the top of
my head are you are you talking about in
temporary accommodation or on the
housing right let let me get that bigger
off Amma and I'll let you know thank
you okay um other councilors president
do you have any questions councelor
McLaren thank you chair um interested
enough Council s has already touched on
something that concerned me
um we we have got sort of reactive
programs to deal with tenants who
actually cannot afford their increased
rents and expenses but my concern is
about all those people that are outside
what you would call the benefits
catchment what as a council are we or
what as a housing provider are we going
to support how are we going to support
these residents who don't fit into that
and need advice and support as we
looking at the sheltered housing scheme
um charges that is over1 18s a week that
these tenants are going to have to find
and I'm just concerned about those that
are outside of the net the safety
net thank you I think I'll have to pass
that one over to deboro as well thank
thank you thank you for the question
again so so there's a couple of things
we'll be doing firstly the schemes all
have um scheme managers and they will be
able to support um the the residents
individually with any with any
challenges they may have the um the the
second thing we can do is is um utilize
our um AI our um Mo our
mobisoft um software which um uses AI to
predict when people are going to go into
um debt so when they're struggling with
their rent and then we can um we can use
that data to get our income officers and
also our financial inclusion officers
for which we have two to work with those
residents to help them budget and um the
increases May well take some of our
residents actually in to the realm where
they can claim benef benefits so so it's
quite an important piece of work that to
to to to um you know take those
steps thank you deborra thank you chair
thank you
debah any other
questions in which case moving on to
Cabinet debate does anyone wish to to
make any comment about the HRA budget at
this
stage we all happy with it
it it's all fairly self-explanatory I
think in in my introduction I uh covered
off all of the the key points but um uh
if everyone's happy with the H budget
we'll move to the
vote thank move to the vote please yeah
that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is five votes for
that's
unanimous um brings us on to the the end
of the meeting and um thank thank you
for members of the cabinet for um
getting to this stage with with both of
those budget papers um we'll now move on
to to council for for final approval and
Adoption of those budgets um probably be
an interesting debate um there'll
probably be quite a few questions which
will need to be answered but um we'll
have the final uh Council reports
prepared very soon ready for the meeting
on on the 20th of this month in terms of
next cabinet meeting uh the next cabinet
meeting is scheduled for Monday the 4th
of March at 400 p.m. so now I'd like to
draw the meeting to a close thank you
everyone